syphilis is a type of sexually
transmitted disease or infection
it's more common in men than women
the infection commonly affects your
genitals which are the reproductive
organs inside and outside of your body
it can also affect your anal area and
the last part of your large intestine
called the rectum
your lips tongue or other parts of your
body may also be affected
the germs that cause the infection are
tiny spiral or coiled bacteria called
treponema pallidum
you can catch the bacteria through
sexual contact with a person who
currently has syphilis especially
someone who has syphilitic sores in or
around their genitals or mouth and
pregnant women who have syphilis can
pass the disease to their unborn child
the bacteria can enter your body through
tiny Cuts or scrapes in your skin or the
tissue that lines many of your body
cavities including the tissue lining
your mouth genitals or anus
within a few hours the bacteria can
spread throughout your body to cause
infection
from there syphilis has four disease
stages with varying symptoms that can
occur over a period of 10 or more years
the primary stage the secondary stage
the latent stage and the tertiary stage
in the primary stage you may have one or
more very infectious but often painless
sores called shankers that appear within
a few days or weeks
they occur at the site where the
bacteria entered your body such as in on
or around the penis
vagina
anus
rectum
or mouth
these sores May last for several weeks
if not treated the disease will progress
to the secondary stage
during this stage in addition to sores a
rash may appear on one or more areas of
your body
other symptoms during this stage may
include fever
headaches
sore throat swollen lymph nodes patches
of hair loss
weight loss muscle aches
and fatigue
since other diseases also have these
symptoms syphilis is sometimes referred
to as the great imitator
the latent or hidden stage usually
begins about one to two years after the
infection started
during this stage the sores and rashes
are no longer visible and other symptoms
have gone away but without treatment the
bacteria will stay in your body
this stage May last for years and you
may still be able to spread the disease
to others
the tertiary stage of Syphilis is rare
but may appear 10 to 30 Years After The
Infection started
during this stage the bacteria May
spread to many other areas of your body
including your brain and nerves
eyes
heart and blood vessels
liver
and bones and joints
the symptoms will depend on where it has
spread
having tertiary syphilis is very serious
because it can damage your internal
organs and can be fatal
the main risk for getting syphilis is
having contact with a sore during
vaginal anal or oral sex with a person
who has the infection
you may have a higher risk if you are
sexually active and are a man who has
sex with men
have the human immunodeficiency virus or
HIV
take medicine to prevent HIV
or have one or more partners that have
syphilis
at any stage untreated syphilis May
spread to other areas of your body for
example neurosyphilis happens when it
spreads to your brain and nerves
symptoms of neurosyphilis can include
headaches weak muscles and trouble
moving and mental problems such as
confusion or trouble with Focus memory
thinking or making decisions
ocular syphilis occurs when syphilis
spreads to your eyes
symptoms of ocular syphilis can include
eye pain or redness
vision changes
or even blindness
and if syphilis spreads to your ears
it's called Oto syphilis
symptoms of Oto syphilis can include
hearing loss A ringing or buzzing sound
in your ears called tinnitus
dizziness or a feeling that you or
everything around you is moving or
spinning called vertigo
if you think you might have symptoms of
syphilis or want to find out more about
it talk to your Healthcare practitioner
thank you